في تركيا احد ميادين التنازع بين الحكومه
والمعارضه يراه حزب العداله والتنميه
انجازا تاريخيا يعزز ديمقراطيه وينهي
ارسال انقلابات وتغده المعارضه نظاما يعزز
سلطه الرجل الواحد وتتوعد في كل مناسبه
بالغائه والعوده الى النظام البرلماني
الذي ظل قائما حتى عام 2017 فما ابرز
الفوارق بين النظامي الرئاسي والبرلماني
النظام البرلماني يقوم على الموازنه بين
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه فينتخب
الشعب البرلمان الذي يختار الحكومه
بالاغلبيه وهنا تكون الحكومه مسؤوله امام
البرلمان الذي يحق له حلها بنزع الثقه
منها ولا صلاحيات حقيقيه للرئيس
وهذا النظام قائم في دول عده ابرزها
بريطانيا والهند اما في النظام الرئاسي
فينتخب الشعب مباشره الرئيس والبرلمان
تكون السلطه التنفيذيه بيد الرئيس الذي
يتمتع بصلاحيات اوسعه ويجمع بين رئاسه
الدوله ورئاسه الحكومه المنبثقه منها
وتكون الحكومه مسؤوله امام الرئيس وليس
امام البرلمان ولا يمكن للرئيس الغاء
البرلمان ولا يمكن للبرلمان عزل الرئيس
الا في حالات الخيانه العظمى وبشرط
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه ومن الدول التي تعمل
بذلك النظام الولايات المتحده وهناك نظام
ثالث يعرف بالمختلط او شبه الرئاسي ينتخب
فيه الرئيس والبرلمان بالاقتراع العام
المباشر ويتمتع فيه الرئيس بقدر كبير من
الصلاحيات وفي الوقت نفسه تكون هناك حكومه
منبثقه من البرلمان ولها رئيس يتمتع
بصلاحيات اخرى يختاره رئيس الدوله وتكون
الحكومه مسؤوله امام كل من البرلمان
والرئيس ومثاله النظام القائم في فرنسا
حدثونا ما نظام الحكم القائم في بلدكم